the the rockets will take on the lakers
after
escaping a seven game series against okc
how about
the finish of this game and the
execution
or lack of it by okc doesn't look like
steven adams
you could hit him on the lob right there
to the to the hole you know
the thing was scary they had two chances
i didn't what i didn't know what play
they were running
yeah like this is not a play nobody's
setting picks
guys are just moving around like look
nobody said a pick on anybody
and like it was just awful offensive
execution
but where's chris paul going like what
play is this why is chris paul not
getting the ball
he's proven he should hide the ball
right well to me it looks like they were
trying to rust
looked like they were trying to run a
play for dolla galinari
why and russ cheated but it was awful
actually paul got to get that ball
well listen yeah well i thought that
chris paul should have had the ball the
first time yeah
i mean i don't think you drawing up a
play even though dort had had a terrific
game
i don't think you'd get a ball to shake
gilders alexander and say you dribble
off and give it to lou dart on the side
that ball should have been in chris
paul's hand and he should have made to
play
for good or bad well i think i think
shea is going to be a a great young
player
but for instance when he passed that
ball to lou dort chris paul not passing
him that ball
he can be as open as me and you right
now chris paul not giving dork that ball
so
get the ball to cp that was a huge
mistake by billy donovan what
uh shaq what's the first thing that
jumps out of you
about a rockets lakers series and what
are you going to be watching
most intently well chuck draymond and i
are considered big men i want to see if
the small ball
really works uh you know especially
against big you know a.d is a
forward slash center he can match up
with with anybody i want to see how
they're going to defend him
i want to see how they're going to
offensive and defensive rebound
and i want to see if it works and uh
james harden has to
play a lot better you know he's you know
mvp talking all that but
uh for the past couple years and in game
seven it's like he's had a mental block
so
they got out of that series into this
new series and this is where you you
know make a name for yourself
against lebron and the lakers they have
beaten the lakers with that small ball
lineup beat him in february and when a
game when westbrook had
41 and hardin only had 14. did anthony
davis and lebron play
anthony davis had 32 and 13 and lebron
had 18 9 and 15.
that's uh i thought two of those games
they didn't play
well there there was no ad in the first
game okay
and there was no a.d in the bubble i
mean there was no lebron there was a
okay so in the bubble but that other
game in february yeah
ernie as great as the first round was
in the western conference i think these
these two series in the west going to be
awful
i think it's just a bad matchup for the
rockets
i think they're just too little and i
think anthony davis
dwight howard javel mcgee gonna go crazy
on the offensive board
uh so i don't think this is gonna be a
good series draymond you got the last
word on it
um i think i think i i think houston has
a chance
you know but what it's going to boil
down to is if the other guys for the
lakers
can step up if kcp can have a great
series if danny green can have a
good series because someone has to match
the three-point
shooter that the rockets have and so if
those guys can step
up they should put the rockets away
pretty easily
that one starts tomorrow night